mon rêve c'est que dans quelques années
ils ont peut-être dans cinq dix ans vous
puissiez écrire dans vos dissertation
des phrases comme romain treffel écrit
dans son histoire de la philosophie que
blablabla mais il faut que je fasse
attention parce que vous ne pouvez pas
mobilisé n'importe quelle référence dans
une dissertation
[Musique]
petite précision pour commencer pour que
tout soit bien clair dans votre esprit
quand je parle de référence cédant
instance générale ce n'est pas
obligatoirement un essai ou un livre de
fiction ça peut être un article un
discours un poème une oeuvre d'art et
c'est une référence c'est un produit de
la culture qui fait autorité c'est à
dire que les sociétés estiment qu'il
faut reconnaître la valeur de ce produit
culturel et qu'il faut aussi soumettre
par exemple un essai philosophique est
une référence au sens où on estime qu'il
a fait progresser la pensée une peinture
peut être une référence au sens où on
estime qu'elle nous a permis de jeter
sur le monde un regard nouveau
je veux aussi vous rappeler la fonction
d'une référence en dissertation une
référence sert à apporter du crédit le
crédit d'une autorité extérieure reconnu
une référence sert à apporter du crédit
à un argument donc une référence ne sert
pas à montrer que vous avez appris votre
cour que vous êtes cultiver ou
impressionner le correcteur d'accord si
vous voulez vous faire valoir auprès du
correcteur ce n'est pas au niveau des
références que ça se passe ça se passe
au niveau de la méthodologie et pour ça
j'ai ce qu'il vous faut inscrivez-vous à
mon cours gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo plus de 30 mille élèves
l'ont déjà suivi et j'ai reçu beaucoup
du mail de remerciement
donc je n'ai aucun doute que ça va vous
plaire à vous aussi
inscrivez vous maintenant pour ne pas
oublier mais vous pourrez découvrir mon
cours après cette vidéo ou dans les
prochains jours parce que c'est un cours
par e-mail
là tout de suite concentrez-vous pour
regarder attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout dans dix minutes
la sélection des références n'aura plus
de secret pour vous et cela vous fera
gagner des points dès votre prochaine
épreuve de dissertation
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de la fameuse dissertation de culture
générale sur le sujet y at il encore des
grands hommes qui de mémoire a été notée
19 sur 20 au concours d'entrée de l'ena
cette dissertation on me l'a montré
quand je préparais ce concours je me
souviens que les élèves étaient en
extase quand il la lisait il était en
extase parce que dans cette copie il y a
littéralement une référence par phrase
est du coup les élèves qui la lisent
sans réfléchir en déduit ce qu'il faut
gaver le correcteur de référence
mais ces élèves manquent cruellement de
pragmatisme
ils ne comprennent pas que cette copie
si brillante soit elle constitue un
mauvais exemple
eh bien oui parce qu'un bon modèle c'est
un modèle que vous pouvez facilement
imiter vous croyez vraiment que vous
allez apprendre 10000 références ici
votre prochaine dissertation ou même
d'ici votre épreuves de concours mais
surtout vous croyez vraiment que vous
serez capable de les mobiliser dans une
dissertation
bien sûr que non posez vous la question
comment certains élèves parviennent ils
à écrire des dissertations que vous
trouvez ultra-brillantes des
dissertations et bourré de références
en fait il y a deux possibilités la
première c'est que l'élève ait eu un
coup de chance il est super calé sur un
thème précis et le sujet qui tombe porte
sur ce thème
je connais par exemple quelqu'un qui
avait écrit un mémoire sur l'art dans
les régimes totalitaires et qui a passé
un concours où le sujet d'une époque de
dissertation était justement sur la
culture dans les régimes totalitaires
cet étudiant n'était pas
particulièrement doué en dissertation
mais là il a cartonné la seconde
hypothèse qui explique que certains
élèves parviennent à écrire des
dissertations que vous trouvez
ultra-brillantes des dissertations
bourré de références c'est que même soit
brillant et j'en ai connu des comme ça
leurs deux parents sont profs en prépa
ou à l'université ou bien ils ont les
diplômes des écoles les plus
prestigieuses et du coup les enfants ont
eu le nez dans les livres et entendu des
conversations brillante depuis leur plus
jeune âge là en terme de connaissance
pure vous ne pouvez pas lutter voici
pourquoi les copies bourré de références
sont de mauvais modèle la première règle
pour choisir à l'adhérence c'est donc de
faire l inverse
choisissez une seule et unique référence
par argument choisissez une référence
qui est pertinente et que vous maîtrisez
puis expliqué dans le paragraphe en quoi
elles crédibilisent votre argument si
vous essayer d'impressionner le
correcteur en accumulant les références
elles seront moins pertinente vous les
expliquerez moins bien elles ne seront
probablement pas cohérentes les unes par
rapport aux autres et les transitions de
l'une à l'autre seront probablement
maladroite
la première règle découle d'un phénomène
bien connu très souvent la qualité des
croix avec la quantité
d'après mon expérience vous vous
débrouillerez donc bien mieux en vous
concentrant sur une seule et unique
référence par arguments allez on passe à
la deuxième règle
[Musique]
vous imaginez vous citer une bande
dessinée dans une dissertation de
culture générale au concours d'entrée de
l'ena
honnêtement ou moi je ne prendrais pas
le risque mais je me souviens qu'un de
mes profs avaient raconté qu'un de ses
élèves avaient décroché 16 sur 20 ans
culture générale au concours de l'ena
avec une accroche sur lucky luke c'est
sûr qu'avec cette accroche
il est sorti du lot la référence a dû
surprendre le correcteur donc elle est
originale d'un côté lucky luke
appartient bien au patrimoine culturel
de la francophonie
mais de l'autre la bande dessinée c'est
un support qui apparaîtra moins nobles
aux yeux du correcteur maintenant j'ai
une autre anecdote à vous raconter
il ya quelques années dans la classe
d'un de mes élèves le prof avait
expliqué qu'une copie de culture
générale pouvait se démarquer en
mobilisant des références artistiques
comme il y avait dix à certains élèves
s'étaient mis à citer exclusivement des
tableaux quel que soit le sujet quel que
soit l'argument is it est un tableau à
la con s'il n'était pas tombé dans
l'oreille d'un sourd en les élèves ne
s'était pas posé la question combien de
référence d'original une bonne
dissertation doit-elle comporter alors
par principe vous ne pouvez pas
mobiliser une majorité de références
originales mais où placer le curseur
pour faire simple je vous conseille de
viser une proportion de paraître c'est à
dire environ 80% de références
classiques et 20% de références
originales c'est la deuxième règle pour
choisir les références après c'est au
doigt mouillé bien sûr par exemple si
vous lobby lisez en tout 9 10 références
à de votre dissertation autorisez-vous
maximum 2 3 références originales si
vous de mobiliser que six références
autorisez-vous maximum une ou deux
références d'original et puis idéalement
ne m'étais pas toutes les références
d'original dans la même grande partie
c'est mieux de les disperser mais bon ça
c'est un détail
la réussite de votre dissertation ne se
joue pas à ça et pour vous dire la
vérité ce n'est pas crucial que vous
mobilisiez des références originales
vous pouvez très bien décrocher une
bonne note en mobilisant exclusivement
des références classiques
en revanche vous prenez un risque si
vous mobiliser trop de références
origine
parce que le correcteur pensera
probablement que vous ne maîtrisez pas
les références classiques
donc mon conseil c'est apprenez en
priorité des références classiques ne
vous prenez pas la tête avec les
références originales et si vous voulez
en mobiliser souvenez vous qu elles
doivent être minoritaire dans la
dissertation après il y a des références
que vous devez purement et simplement
éviter
[Musique]
imaginez que vous rédiger une
dissertation sur l'amour est ce que
c'est une bonne idée de site et 50
nuance degrés si vous pensez que oui
alors vous faites vraiment bien de
regarder cette vidéo
eh bien non c'est une mauvaise idée
parce que 50 nuance degrés c'est une
référence vulgaire ce n'est bien
évidemment pas une référence classique
je sais même pas si on peut dire que
c'est une référence
original mais c'est une référence
vulgaire parce qu'il est admis qu elle
ne lève pas l'esprit humain ça changera
peut-être avec le temps mais pour
l'instant 50 nuance de grêle n'a pas
accédé au statut de référence noble ne
confondait donc pas les références
originales et les références vulgaire
une référence original peut avoir un
effet rafraîchissant
parce que par définition elle va
surprendre le correcteur en revanche une
référence vulgaire vous attirera le
mépris du correcteur et peut donc vous
faire perdre beaucoup de points les
références vulgaire appartiennent
généralement à la culture populaire
récente disons des vingt trente
dernières années 50 nuance degrés par
exemple un livre de 2012 est un film de
2015 dont il est trop récent pour
figurer dans une dissertation mais il ne
le sera peut-être plus en 2040 ou en
en comparaison en lucky luke a été créée
dans les années 1940 1950 il existe une
autre raison de vous censurez concernant
les références la controverse
si vous écriviez une dissertation au
xviie siècle je vous déconseille ray de
citer des auteurs explicitement athées
ou qui remettent en question la version
de l'histoire de l'humanité donné par la
bible ne dis pas que dieu n'existe pas
ni que la bible est un récit mensonger
jeudi qu'il y a plusieurs centaines
d'années remettre en question
l'existence de dieu ou bien le récit
public cela suscitait la controverse
au point qu'un correcteur de
dissertation condamnerait ses idées eh
bien il est raisonnable de penser que
c'est pareil à chaque époque certaines
idées controversées ou politiquement
incorrecte sont susceptibles de heurter
la sensibilité d'une personne que vous
ne connaissez pas personnellement donc
si vous craignez qu'une référence ne
soit trop controversé abstenez-vous de
la mobiliser vous pouvez éventuellement
vous le permettre à deux conditions
si vous tirez l'analyse la référence
controversé d'une référence tierces qui
fait autorité
par exemple si vous l'a tirée d'un
manuel d'histoire des idées politiques
et seconde condition si vous introduisez
la référence controversé avec tact en en
condamnant au moins implicitement le
propos oui je sais bien je vous
conseille de vous auto censuré mais ce
n'est pas la lâcheté qui inspire ce
conseil c'est la réalité des rapports
humains qui vous commande de le suivre
par pragmatisme votre correcteur n'est
pas prêt à tout lire donc vous devez
être prudents
[Musique]
je vous rappelle rapidement les trois
règles vous devez choisir une seule et
unique référence par argument vous devez
mobiliser maximum 20% de références
originales et enfin vous devez éviter
les références vulgaire ou trop
controversé mais encore une fois comme
je lé déjà dire beaucoup de vidéos les
références ne sont pas l'enjeu essentiel
de l'exercice de la dissertation ce
n'est pas en vous prenant la tête avec
les références que vous progresserez en
dissertation pour progresser vous avez
besoin d'une méthodologie solide donc
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant haut à
droite de la vidéo soit qu'en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo
après même si la méthodologie c'est bien
plus important que la sélection des
références j'espère comme d'habitude que
cette vidéo vous sera utile je suis
romain je suis toujours avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sur mille idées
de culture générale rappelez vous que
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour bien choisir vos références
en dissertation
[Musique]